好的各位同学
现在是第三堂课
第三堂课要跟大家讨论的议题是
何谓中国风歌词
中国风这三个字
我相信某些时候已经跟我划上等号了
因为中国风的歌词它是一个类别
它比较好讨论
而且呢他创作上的一个要求度
比一般的流行歌词来得高
他的遣词用语需要去经营文字的结构
需要有耐人咀嚼的一个想象空间
之所以有这样子的一个类别作品
只因为创作的当下
我就想到说你要具备一个不可被取代性
当初创作的时候
我就在想情歌
大家都会写
那情歌无非就是失恋的
然后热恋的暧昧的别人也会写情歌
你也会写情歌
为什么非得你写不可
你有什么理由一定要在这个圈子占一个位置
那我就在想好吧
既然一样讲情歌
既然一样是情歌的范畴
那我可不可以把情歌的时空背景
架作在某一个朝代
让一样是情歌的一个背景空间
有古风的韵味
当初是因这样思考
才有所谓中国风一系列的创作
这个是我当下思索的一个问题
你绝对不能写别人也会写的歌词
那你随时有被取代的一个可能性
所以呢你要创造出一种比较旗帜鲜明的类别
那这个类别对我来讲就是中国风
何谓中国风呢
中国风的这个风到底是什么意涵
显而易见
这个风指的就是曲风
那什么是曲风呢
举例来讲
可能像节奏蓝调
灵魂乐
爵士
甚至于乡村音乐
民谣风
摇滚电音说唱
还有雷鬼重金属这些所谓的音乐类别
你可以在一开始的前面几小节的一个旋律
或者是伴奏的一个编曲上就马上判断哦
这是电音哦
这是HIPHOP说唱的音乐
甚至都不用进入到人生的vocal
只有前奏一部分
你就可以判断出来
为什么
因为你根据的是前面它的旋律的一个节奏
和弦的走向
拍子的速度
音阶的使用范围跟特定的作曲模式
这些综合判断
让你可以很轻易的从一首歌的前面几小节
就判断出哦
这是电音哦
这是雷鬼哦
这是民谣风
这是RMV
因有这些音乐的元素去支撑你做判断
甚至也不用那么复杂
所有的音乐三要素就是旋律
和弦跟节奏
通常有音乐素养的人
可能几秒就知道这是什么类别的歌了
这些才是音乐定义上的所谓的曲风
但是中国风不是这样子的
为什么中国风很特别
中国风的判断标准居然是歌词本身居然是文字
而不是音乐
举例来讲
你肯定有听过摇滚版的中国风
有RMB的中国风
甚至有民谣风
很轻柔的中国风
但最标准的中国风是所谓的五声音阶
宫商角子羽
这个是最没有争议的中国风
但音乐的创作的形态不是这样子定义的
所以跟各位同学分享一个概念
记得所有的中国风是创作的概念跟方向
而不是音乐定义上的
曲风
所以音乐的定义是说他有特定的作曲模式
它有一个固定的节奏
和弦的走向
让你在前面的几小节就可以马上听出哦
这是hip hod
这是摇滚的
这是美国的乡村音乐
这些是可以判断的
因为他的依据是音乐
就是我刚刚讲的音乐的三要素
节奏旋律跟和弦
这是很容易判读的
但是中国风很耐人寻味
他判读的标准居然有一个是歌词文字
那今天跟各位同学分享
这个判读的标准有三个要素
第一个要素就是最传统的五声音阶
五声音阶基本上是中国特有的一个趋势
就是流行音乐创作的一种格式
去判读所谓的中国风
这个事只是标准之一而已
那个标准是纵使这首歌是摇滚的
但是只要他的编曲
记得编曲前面可能拉一段二胡间奏
可能弹个古筝
然后收尾有琵琶的声音
这个也是可以被归类为中国风
因为他的编曲
他的乐器上有使用到传统乐器
这里的传统乐器范围非常的广
更有横笛
洞箫
琵琶
古筝甚至古琴都可以
因为这些东方韵味的古乐器
会让这首歌带有浓厚的东方情调
所以大家听觉上就把它归类为中国风
另外一个是歌词的判断标准
歌词上如果用到仿古诗词韵味的词汇
譬如伊人拱桥
蹙眉
月下烟雨这样子的词汇
它有个年代性
它有个画面感
基本上流行歌的空间感不会用到
流行歌的空间感跟霓虹灯
可能玻璃橱窗
可能咖啡馆
那它的词汇里面不可能出现触媒
这眉头皱起来只有蹙眉拱桥
月下伊人江南烟雨这些
它就是符合中国风的定义
所以所谓中国风的创作
它的定义是广泛的
只要符合编曲上用到古乐器
歌词的文字结构
有仿古诗词的一个韵味
甚至于它的曲式是所谓的五声音阶
只要符合某一项
基本上它就是所谓的中国风传
创作
那再跟各位同学分享的
就是说
中国风只是我们比较常常创作的一个音乐类别
或所谓的作词风格
但是中国风不是我们发明的
早就有这样子的创作风格
像黄章的那个沧海一声笑就很经典
像早期台湾的校园民歌里面其实有一个小区块
他就蛮符合所有的中国风
很像金山古道
很像365里路文章的歌
我还记得刚开始接触校园民歌的时候
我还读国小
那我就觉得诶好特别
居然有一种音乐的类型
是是我那个年纪就喜欢的
所以我觉得说创作来自于一个人的价值观啊
或是这个人的那种文化想象吧
其实所有的中国风应该在我心里面扎根很久了
只是说我根本不晓得这个世界上有一种职业类
比较歌词叫词作人
我国小的年纪
我怎么能想象这个世界有多大
职业类别
有多多多远
我是没办法想象的
我只知道说哎这样子的音乐类型吸引我
那我可能会比较呃去收集啦
或者去买买卡带来提
那时候还流行卡带
我就觉得诶好像说你的个人的一种情怀
或是人格特质
本来就会被这个领域所吸引
等到我确定要往这个方向走的时候
我就会付出跟别人不一样的努力
同学们记得我当初是怎么进来唱片圈的
当初是因为我开始去搜集别人的创作
然后借由别人的创作去填词
重新填
那时候可能有李宗盛老师的凡人歌
或是伍佰老师的挪威的森林
我把这些我那时候喜欢的歌我重新填上
我的歌词
就是我用我的歌词去取代原来的歌词
顺便练习歌词的结构
有点像书法的临帖
你知道吧
因为书法有书法底等
他通常需要拿一些大师的书法去练
他的笔画跟结构跟笔顺跟中锋怎么转
怎么用
这个一定要临帖
临帖完之后
你的布局的结构才会有底气
这是很重要的
所以我当初把别人的歌词抽换掉
变成自己的文字的时候
有点像书法的临帖
我觉得这个功用蛮大的
各位同学不妨试试看
就说你甚至可以推翻我的青花瓷啊
菊花台去填上你的文字
用这个形式当做练习
再接着跟大家分享当初投稿的一个过程
我当初下定决心要开始从事音乐
创作歌词作品的时候
你们知道吗
我投了100份
我投了100份哦
20几年前不是每一家都有电脑
而且那个电脑的软体基本上很多格式也不支援
那时候可能还停留在286吧
我们是请打字行打的
我手写
我把歌词手写在稿纸上
请打字行把我打成排版美观的字
然后我自己还分部首哦
比如说一字步在第几页有一字布这样毁
然后痛
然后二字不叫离开
难过我还弄个目录
你知道吗
就是我写了100首
等我想说人家翻来翻去
突然对那首歌有印象
他怎么办
那我就做个索引目录
然后把歌名放在首页
然后歌名下面的页码就对照他在几页
几页的那个排版上
就是找打字行打字
然后去大学附近找人家装订
你大学附近有装订论文的那些装订行嘛
他帮我装订
然后我装订了100份
我为什么要记住100份呢
那时候我就在想
如果我只记住一份到滚石
你就给李宗盛老师
他他不见得有空看嘛
他也没有义务一定要看嘛
那就石沉大海了
所以那时候我用一个三去法
就是我寄出100份
那我就设想说总机的小妹他会自己决定嘛
因为他是收收发信件的人
他可能某种程度把他当做是歌迷的回行卡
或歌迷要送的礼物
那通常就挡掉50份了
我想说几百份的原因是
因我有50份要给总机小妹收发信件
去挡掉50份
那还有50份啦
制作人有助理
因为我当初记的时候
我是按照卡带后面的唱片公司的名字
我寄给歌手跟制作人
我寄给这222大类的一个音乐人
制作人有助理
那歌手有宣传
那这50份到了宣传跟助理的手上又砍掉一半
我们家歌手这么忙
我们家制作人这么忙
他怎么会有一定收到什么样的东西
是一定传上去
他一看这个甚至我都认为说他只要印刷品
他都应该都有全过滤
他可能会拆开来看好吧
总计小妹过滤掉50份的
剩下的50份再除以二
因为这个助理跟宣传
不见得会拿给歌手跟制作人
那有25份
真的交到了这个资准跟歌手手里了
但是我们又没有亲戚关系
又不是谁去委托他
也没有第一时间有那个义务要看嘛
好吧
那这25份制作人跟歌手有空看的人
可能就剩下12.5
我才记100份
那这12点我就算看了
他也不见得有兴趣
一定要打给你吧
一定要跟你联系吧
好我再除以二
但剩下5~6
我想说我一定要切出100份
最后才会有5~6个至尊或歌手
他有时间有空也愿意打开来看
那打开看的当下
他在有一个动机
或有一个觉得还可以的那个意念
然后打电话给你
那时候没有手机
然后我是留呼叫器
所有的BB扣台湾的用语或家里的电话
我想说应该5~6个人会打给我吧
我等了快一个月
只有宪哥打给我哈
后来我才知道说为什么宪哥打给我
那时候他在主持一个节目叫超级新人王
然后杰伦去参加超级新人王的词曲创作大赛
那是因为这样子他收了很多人的作品
那刚好可能缺文字这个区块
哎好吧
写那么认真
写了那么多
可能有几首他觉得还不错
我记得是7月份
1997年的7月份
因为那个日子对我讲很有意义嘛
宪哥亲自打给我
我在想说
我会被我朋友恶作剧
他说他是吴宗宪
我心里面就OS1你知道吗
我说你吴宗宪我还领养港什么的
我想说不可能啊
宪哥的位置怎么会亲自打给你
后来发现真的是宪哥党
因为那个声音
就像我在电视上看到那个声音一样嘛
我就很开心
然后就哦终于寄出了100份
只有一份有回函
你不知道回函的
他直接打给你
然后找我去录音室找他
那时候的录音室在中广
中广还没有盖大楼
中广那时候有有有录音棚
我去中广找
直接找宪哥
这个是我毛遂自荐的一个过程
就是跟各位同学讲
一定要耐心
一定要恒心跟毅力
音乐这条路不好走
而且呢永远记得你喜欢音乐
不代表音乐一定能接纳你
兴趣不见得能直接等于职业
譬如说你喜欢画画
但是你不见得能依靠插画去养活你的生活
你喜欢创作
你喜欢是你喜欢
但是你要进入
把兴趣等于职业
把兴趣变成职业
你就要跟人家竞争
他就有个门槛喽
你可能喜欢唱歌
你可能是朋友间
同学间在K房里面唱的最好的
但是你是在那个领域里面唱的最好
那你要跟人家竞争的时候
那个门槛更高
我喜欢歌词创作是我喜欢
那并不代表我有那个水平
所以我一定要记很多
让人家看到哦
原来这个还还可以
还可以在训练或者是某种程度的给他机会
所以永远记得可以把兴趣当职业的人真好
也真少
兴趣纯粹是兴趣的时候就很开
就很快乐
没有压力
没有负担
你登山
你画画
你摄影
你拍照
你你写歌
你写小说
你写写文字
作品纯粹是兴趣的时候就没有压力
但是你要变成职业的时候
就一定要竞争
竞争就会有失败
就会有挫折
那这些作者当然日后会变成你的一个故事
这是我最后一个章节要讲的
当个有故事可以说的
所以同学们记得
想在这个圈子变成一个专业的音乐人
或是作词者
这条路很漫长
很艰辛
但是值得走
为什么起码你到了五六十岁的时候
回过头去看自己
哎我20几岁的时候喜欢写歌词
哦啊我有尝试过
因为你尝试过失败
跟从头到尾没有尝试是不一样的
因为有时候我们的人
我们的企图心会大于能力
性大于能力
就就是个不好收拾这个困境的
就是你你你想要做很多很多事情
但是你能力没有跟上
能力是要后天的努力跟吸收
所以记得音乐的追求
是年轻时期的一个热血的梦
不管最终有没有成功
起码你活过了
起码你做到了
起码你有去争取的
那这一切就值得了
刚刚讲的那些中国风的歌词
创作的一个判断的标准
是希望让各位同学知道说哦
原来所谓的中国风是创作的概念跟方向
它不是听觉
也不是音乐上被定义的趋势
至于这样子的一个创作的概念跟方向
我认为他会永远不退
流行
永远在华语流行音乐里面占一个百分比
这个百分比跟类别有点像电影的那种呃片型
比如说可能有枪战片
有悬疑片
有恐怖片
有爱情片
有灾难片
有历史片
那中国风这样子的创作
会在华语流行音乐里面永远占一个区块
那我认为这个百分比是永远都会存在着